Oh, hello there!
Oh don't mind me, I'm just walking in the jungle.
Or am I?
That's right.
I'm in space.
or am I?
That's right.
I'm in the jungle again.
*Everybody's mind blows*
I can tell that you have a
Tough Mind.
This video is not for the weak minded.
This video is going to make you
T H I N K
How can our eyes be real, if you don't have any eyes?   :O
Today we're going to go through the reddit where all the toughest thinkers go to.
Socrates, Plato, if they were still alive, this is where they would spend their time spreading their wisdom.
I'm talking of course about I'm 14. This is deep reddit. Is your mind ready?!
to be blown? ;)
let's begin.
Coincidence or Not?
if ABCDE... ok, equals 1 2 3 4 5 ok, then 11 plus 14
*Knowledge* equals 96%, but "hard work" equals
98% both are important, but fall just short of 100% BUT
"attitude" equals 100%-
*MIND BLOWN BISH*
Now that's- that really makes you think
Coincidence or not? We will never know
but at least we've learned and buttsex that's 110%. Actually it's a...
...111
MOVING ON!!!!!!!!
"This hit me hard"
Instagram
EHEHEHEHEH *inhales*
That's right, this is why I don't have an Instagram cuz I'm a Christian channel
Thank you very much all these sheeps *weird hand gesture*
these sheeps these fools so easily persuaded BY THE DEVIL
on the instagram
Tumblr getting to real guys, okay
It's a light bulb and a mousetrap "this has deeper meaning the light bulb
represents an idea of an individual the mousetrap represents how quickly
Society is to destroy that idea." *chuckles* "Are you fucking retarded?
no
It's just a light bulb falling on a mousetrap stfu"
"guys I don't know what the meaning is
But if it is what the person said you're kind of proving it right. she said her idea
And now you're judging it, just like she said society would
*O SHIET*
I don't like that one either. intelligent people will understand
haHAHAHAHAHAAHAHASBAJSA
That's right having this massive
weight of brain amount
Having this hugely disproportionate brain. Just look at all these happy people, but I'm too smart
To be happy. I've watched one too many episodes of rick and morty and then I knew it was done
Then I knew depression was real.. THE NEXT ONE... parallel lines have a lot in common, but they never meet
Ever. you might think that's sad
But every other pair of lines meets once and then drift apart forever, which is pretty sad
too
*existensial crisis dan howell dat you*
Nothing hits me harder than parallel lines
it's just so deep
I never thought about lines before
uuuuUUuUUUUUhHHhHHhHH *nuts*
This is deep ehUaHAHAHAHAHhahaAA
"I don't know what's going on, but I'm crying on just a thought of bitches thinking they look like Danny Devito"
Dude I'd be so happy if I saw Danny Devito when I look into the mirror then I would truly
Be happy why am I wearing headphones? If there is no audio
*X-Files Music*
Has an iPhone, Mac
Xbox, Playstation 3, Wii
Internet, pocket-money, more than most families budget, NOT HAPPY AT ALL
Use a rock as a camera, THE HAPPIEST KID IN THE WORLD
"I wish I had a rock, some kids are so lucky"
"I wish I had hands, some kids are so lucky"
"I wish I had kids, hands are so lucky" oh my god
It keeps going. this is so sad, "boob"
"book" D:
Next time I see a boob
I will look at a book ten times to compensate 20 times for every boob I see I will look it
200 books. "one single boob"
if the titanic sank in 2017
Everyone would be taking picture. "the fuck am I supposed to do save the ship?"
But at least if we all work together we could do it hashtag #saveTitanic2017 rest in piece (i mean peace)
"I'm fine" "save me"
*boob pat*
If only one person would open their eyes this person could be saved notice how her her her toe is like
Perfectly aligned with the knee that's kind of trippy
It looks like she's growing nails out of her knee that's disgusting (no shit sherlock)
"when you clean out a vacuum cleaner..." *laughs*
sorry "when you clean out a vacuum cleaner you become a
Vacuum cleaner" have you ever thought about that I bet you haven't thought about that one
*laughs*
*inhales* Mm-hmm a
"a psychologist came to my class and was talking to us, then he asked a question. He said tell me
Would you rather get shot or get heartbroken?
No one was answering so I did and I said shot, and he asked why? I said
Because getting shot can be healed
He looked at me and said who agrees with her?
No one answer, then he said that none of you have had your heart broken
they don't know the pain
they don't know the pain. It's like getting shot with a 50 Cal
straining the nuts (dafuq)
That's how it feels and even that can heal you can heal you can grow back your nuts, but you can't grow back a heart (life lessons with papi poods)
cHrIstIAN ChAnNeL
"People think it's fun and cool to be
"woke"
lol, it's actually pretty shitty and
frustrating being conscious in an unconscious
society" basically
society
You. here. me?
I'm about I'm here looking down on you, and I think well those those people look pretty dumb
It's so hard being this WOKE. You don't understand the suffering of my intellect yes
This is my man
Neil what is he saying?
"almost all armed conflict in the history of the world came about because
Opposing science believed different things to be true." Oh my god
Are you telling me?
Are you telling me that people have different ideas and opinions? no!
Neil that is too far even my open mind
I refuse to accept this as a fact. Neil go back to your science and stay away from deep
thinkers like me
*growls* (papi pewds is hangry)
I'm gonna destroy you
"dad
Just remember next time you take my iPhone or iPad you take away
my happiness"
ah it's so true
"poodiepie is basically shitposting with his career at this point"
what makes you think.. *laughs*
That's right when this video ends your happiness will also disappear, but don't worry. There is another video
waiting for you. "grab a plate and throw it on the floor
AHHHH
Did it break? Yes. now say sorry to it. Sorry
Did it go back to how it was before?
NOOOOO
Do you understand
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
oh jaden
"It's your birthday Mateo said. I didn't respond
Are you not excited to be 15? he asked
Reading my book. I uttered I turned 15
Long ago" because my mind down here, down here. I might be 15
maybe more like 12 but up here
Am a man of old age with many wisdoms and an awesome anime hentai collection.
Would you like to see?
Come come my child come come
by that we're gonna end this episode
leave a like if your mind had been open just a little bit if you learned
something today
Leave 2 likes if you ever read a book. leave 3 likes if you watched
5 Rick and Morty episodes in total. leave 4 likes if Jaden Smith is your wallpaper (mmmmm)
Leave 5 likes, that's impossible
You can't leave 5 likes (everyone give papi 10 likes plz)
now excuse me
While I go into some deeper thought
*thinking intensifies*
Hello there oh
Don't mind me. I'm just walking in the jungle (sure poods)
Or am I?
That's right
(aaaaaaaaaaand he's gone)
(bye guys love you)